[Música]
Y así pues entramos a esta sección para
explicar las noticias económicas del
mundo con nuestro periodista Juan Pablo
lucumí Juan Pablo buenas noches para
ustedes Buenas noches
visitó Puerto Rico ha sido una de
nuestras noticias del día de hoy Cuáles
son las cifras de Esta visita Pues si
nos vamos directamente a las cifras de
los 3,2 millones de personas que viven
en el territorio libre asociado de
Estados Unidos por lo menos 1,4 millones
están por debajo del umbral de la
pobreza es decir un poco más del 40%. el
huracán Fiona que llegó el mes pasado
tiene a más de 137 mil personas sin
electricidad aunque las autoridades han
logrado que el 90% de esa electricidad
sea restablecida a todo esto se le añade
que 66 mil personas están sin servicio
de agua el mandatario estadounidense
hizo la visita pues para inspeccionar
los daños el mismo y aseguró que no
abandonará a Puerto Rico recordando la
polémica de hace cinco años cuando
Donald Trump presidente entonces congeló
miles de millones de ayudas para la isla
y se opuso a enviar más dinero luego del
primer paquete enviado recordemos que el
huracán de 2017 del que estamos hablando
del huracán María fue uno de los más
poderosos del que la isla todavía se
está recuperando bien y por eso los
habitantes protestan y dicen que no ha
sido rápida la Casa Blanca en las ayudas
Pero bueno vamos a seguir hablando de
ministros ahora de la reunión de los
ministros de economía de la eurozona Así
es Ángela los jefes de las carteras de
finanzas de los países que comparten el
euro como moneda prometieron este lunes
unirse para realizar lo que llamaron
escudos financieros nacionales esto es
una señal de unidad luego de que algunos
países de la Unión Europea mostraran su
rechazo al paquete de apoyo que de
manera independiente anunció Alemania el
viernes por 67 mil millones de euros
para ayudar pues a su población a la
unpi debido a los precios de el aumento
de energía por eso es precisamente lo
que les preocupa a los ministros que los
planes económicos de cada país no sean
coordinados temporales y para ayudas
específicas Pues si no es así se podría
desencadenar un crecimiento acelerado de
salarios y de precios y Por ende una
inflación
récord en muchos de ellos ya veremos
entonces Ángela Cuál será su estrategia
Pues el tamaño de ayuda total del
gobierno de la zona Euro para la
economía ya supera el medio millón de
euros algo que va en contra de los
esfuerzos del Banco Central europeo bien
Juan Pablo y la directora del fmi habló
de las claves que podrían llevarnos a
evitar una recesión económica Mundial de
la que hemos venido hablando en estos
últimos meses Así es Ángela cristalina
de ayer lleva dijo que la recesión
global se puede evitar si las políticas
Fiscales de los gobiernos son
consistentes con el endurecimiento de la
política monetaria por ejemplo planes
como el que acabamos de hablar
precisamente que hizo Alemania y que
planea hacer otros países de la zona de
oro irían en contra de las estrategias
para evitar
una decisión global Pues según ella
estas ayudas Fiscales a largo plazo
tienen efectos adversos en la economía
la directora del fmi le pidió a la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos ser
muy cuidadosa con sus políticas de
interés y dijo que de igual manera
algunos países caerán en la recesión el
año que viene escuchemos
que los bancos centrales actúen con
decisión por qué debido a que la
inflación es muy obstinada ahora vemos
un impacto secundario de los precios de
la energía y los alimentos en la
inflación subyacente en muchos países y
si no se detienen sus pasos es malo para
el crecimiento Y esto es muy malo para
los pobres la inflación es un impuesto
para los pobres Juan Pablo y para el
cierre de la jornada económica Cuáles
son los indicadores Ángela pues hoy fue
el mejor día en meses para Wall Street
luego de pasar el peor septiembre en las
últimas dos décadas él es anti ganó un
2,6%, lo cual fue la mayor ganancia
desde julio un cierre positivo motivado
por buenas noticias que ha recibido la
economía del país sobre todo en el
sector de la vivienda las bolsas
europeas también cerraron con ganancias
mediadas por la reunión de ministros de
finanzas que acabamos de hablar y el
anuncio de gobierno del gobierno
británico de la no implementación de su
polémico mini presupuesto en nuestra
región la bolsa de valores de México
registró su primera ganancia de octubre
siendo esta del 1,8%. esto luego de
conocerse un nuevo récord en la remesia
en las remesas hacia México Pues bien
Juan Pablo muchas gracias a ustedes el
agradecimiento también para nuestros
televidentes pero les pido que se queden
con nosotros vamos a nuestras secciones
de directo